good evening everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the executive
committee uh on today thursday the 24th
of march
um first of all i'd like to welcome two
members of the public in the audience
tonight
and also
visiting member councillor stuart wilson
thank you very much indeed for attending
this evening
we move first of all to item one on the
agenda which is apologies for absence
and none have been received and looking
around the room i can understand why
because everyone's here
so there we are um agenda item two
non-members attending um as i just said
councillor stuart wilson
is here item three
minutes of the meeting held on the 10th
of february 2022
members are you
comfortable for me to
sign those minutes as agreed
as an accurate record agreed
thank you very much indeed
item four is to receive any items of uh
or any declarations of interest
are there any declarations members
no one signaling thank you very much
uh item five questions on notice from
councillors
and there are no members
which takes us nicely onto item six
and um there is a report from the review
committee relating to the disposals
framework uh councillor stuart wilson
chairman of the review committee will
introduce the report and take us through
it council wilson thank you chairman um
the review committee reviewed um the
disposal framework on the first of march
and overall there are only three
recommendations
and they were mainly amplifications on
the report
the the first recommendation is that the
consideration of environment and
community social value issues be
included in the disposals framework and
the idea behind this was to be explicit
in the way that
you'd normally do an investment
appraisal but i guess this would be a
divestment appraisal to make sure that
in a systematic way we take account of
tangible
factors so things like social use
community value that sort of thing
and that we don't lose those
the
second recommendation was that the
community groups should not be
disadvantaged in their ability
to bid for assets during the disposal of
council assets
and the concern for members of the
review committee was that there may be
some small community groups we don't
necessarily know about and really the
concern was to do with the
communications channels so how do we
know these people are out there how do
we make sure people are aware that we
are disposing of this asset and it may
be of some use to them
the third recommendation is that a
member working group be established
under the auspices of the portfolio
holder for commercial business local
economy and leisure to consider the use
of risk assessments to inform uh
disposal options and although we
did vote on that at the meeting i
subsequently spoke with the portfolio
holder and really uh
we concluded that perhaps this was quite
niche to be very few times when we would
use a tool such as this and perhaps
setting up a working group maybe
overkill on this
so that that was the recommendations of
the
review committee
so council wilson just says we're clear
uh tonight are you actually suggesting
rather than a member working group which
is an ongoing body
that actually if there were specific it
would be a task and finish group to look
at that specific yeah absolutely i just
want to be clear yeah on
that yes i do yeah because otherwise as
you say if it's ongoing it it's so niche
that we would very rarely use it as the
council absolutely so it's more specific
related task and finish group yeah i
hope i haven't taken the words out no no
you haven't no no
after the meeting i reflected the help
with councillor webb and that's really
the conclusion that we came to okay
that's really helpful and thank you very
much indeed council wilson uh if i can
pass over to the portfolio holder
council of web have you got any comments
um
sorry
yeah so thank you thank you councillor
wilson for continuing to attend review
was helpful and i think we did have an
interesting discussion
as i said the um the first
recommendation i would agree with
although both environmental and social
issues are included in the document
i think it will be welcome to beef that
up slightly and to see certainly the
environmental issues included within
future expressions of interest
in terms of the community groups i'm i
certainly don't feel that any of our
community groups are disadvantaged
within the disposal framework and i
think that's borne out when you look
through section 4.1 which lists the
various
assets that we have disposed of
and the vast majority of them are given
to various community groups
but certainly
i would agree with that comment in terms
of the and the thinking behind it
um in terms of the issues around the
risk assessment
um upon reflection thank you for your
reflections and the conversation that
we've had i'm not sure that is warranted
just looking through the document again
um section five itself is is all about
risk implications and i do feel that
that is covered within the document so
i'm not sure that we actually do need a
task and finish group to do that
particular piece of work but i certainly
do support the first two recommendations
thank you chairman
thank you councillor webb um have any
other members got some comments
councillor smith
thank you
um apologies because i should have
probably brought this up at an earlier
stage as a question it's just on on
6.7 of the report item 2 disposal
um i'm quite quite quite content with
the the report
the questions more about
lower value assets
as
regrettably i i do feel that when we've
got lower value assets
the cost of our bureaucracy the cost of
for instance uh doing a marketing
exercise if we were dealing with the pro
a private treaty would probably
outstrip the value of the asset and i
wonder on those low value
items low value assets how we can still
ensure that we are doing what we need to
do formally as a council
but not
effectively cost ourselves some money in
disposing
uh councillor wilson would you like to
come back on that one
thank you and it wasn't actually brought
up at the meeting but um i mean i've got
experience of this sort of thing in the
past and
funnily enough it ties into risk
management and some
projects so if you treat this as a
project would be very low value and so
you would you would put minimum
effort into
doing that think of this almost as a
reverse procurement really if you're
buying 500 sheets of paper you're not
going to go out to tender and do a
massive exercise so i think it's sort of
the
polar opposite of that really so i agree
with the sentiment and i guess that the
i'm looking at the assistant director
i don't know the internal process of it
but i'm guessing that for low value
you're not going to put a lot of effort
into it so
i completely understand what you're
saying
chairman through you if i can assist um
yeah it's a really good question very
good point these are some of the assets
we have
we're talking about in terms of these
disposals to the community are of low
value in terms of the asset themselves i
agree i think it's when we look at the
social values the social value they add
um to the residents of the community um
essex hackspace taking over hawker
villains good example i think low value
asset yes potentially but the social
value really high in terms of what
they're delivering so you're right in
terms of a disposal process we try and
keep that as simple straightforward as
we can
to that simply by a expression of
interest that we market on our website
and we ask
interested community groups to um
set up how they can deliver the
objectives of the council uh be that
social value benefits um benefits to the
community but also meet our own
safeguarding and health and safety
aspects as well we keep that quite
straightforward we score that
and then we take a view from there in
consultation with a portfolio holder but
certainly for community basis we do try
and keep it simple and streamlined and
make sure we deliver on council's
objectives hope that's helpful um
chairman thank you
thank you very much indeed
wilson happy with that uh yes thank you
chad and councilman smith
yeah
the difficulty with these things is
always it's not just about the
commercial value in terms of pounds it
is about the social values so it's a bit
difficult to put a uh a threshold on it
but i think looking at these
recommendations and i will take them
individually if i may um
because i think three is possibly
something that we need to
look at um but
are there any other points before i move
to the recommendations
okay
right so there are three recommendations
set out at 2.1 of the report the first
one that consideration of environmental
social value issues being included in
the disposal framework um
do we
agree with that agree
the second one that community groups
should not be disadvantaged in their
inability in their ability to bid for
assets during disposal of council assets
do we agree with that
right
and certainly looking through the list
in the report there is clear evidence
that actually those two we do already
but this is actually inserting in the in
the document just to make us consciously
aware of it but i'm quite proud of uh
when you look down the list that was
presented to the review committee of
exactly actually how we've taken our
social obligations um you know very
responsibly and if we move to three
now i accept that this is a
recommendation from your review
committee
but i think there is a danger that we
may not accept it in the executive in
the way it's currently written and it's
not my wish that we should in any way
want to just
clear it off um but uh you know we
referred earlier to task and finish i
wonder whether council wilson you've got
some suggested wording
that we could take as an alternative
that you feel your committee would be
comfortable with and indeed we can
support
um thank you i think the wording may be
a task and finished group to look at how
risk
could i help you please wilson can i
suggest that a task and finish group be
established when disposal of a specific
asset because i think that's what we're
talking about it's it's it's an asset by
asset basis yeah
does that assist you it is yeah and i
think it was just bringing the risk side
of it in but that would be fine yeah
so councillor wilson having assisted you
what's the wording of your
recommendation well you just said with
risk management at the end of it
so establish so to establish a task and
finish group
as
assets are disposed
i think councillor webb is uh itching to
assist as well councilwoman
thank you chairman i'm just wondering if
the wording that could be used would be
that consideration of risk and use of
and the use of risk assessments be
included in the disposal framework but
that we don't actually need to set up a
task and finish group for that
quite small niche piece of work
okay so um if
you would be kind enough just to read
that again as a uh thank you to this
committee
so that consideration of risk and the
use of risk assessments be included in
the disposal framework
that's really
good
i'm just looking to our legal advisors
just to make sure they're comfortable
before we take take that to the vote
are those in favor
agreed
lovely thank you very much indeed and uh
i know councillor wilson you need to
depart but i just want to take this
opportunity to thank you and your
committee for the dialogue and the
really positive work that is going on
not only within the committee but the
new dialogue that goes on with this
committee as well because i think you
know the way this is working is really
good and follows on from the review of
review
that
took place a few months ago so thank you
very much indeed for your positive
engagement on the process thank you
right we move on to item seven which is
the new deed of variation with sanctuary
housing association that's to consider
the report of the chief executive
providing details of a new deed of
variation with sanctuary housing
association i turn to the chief
executive jonathan stevenson
thank you
thank you chairman thank you members um
you've got a report in front of you
tonight item seven um with regard to the
new deal of variation for sanctuary
housing association
um as you can see from the recommended
recommendation is to enter into a new
diversified variation with sanctuary
housing association the reason for this
is the county entered into a agreement
um or a new contractual agreement in
2016
and following
emerging from the um from the pandemic
we've been working with sanctuary in
partnership looked at how we could work
more closely and more align our our work
together um around place shaping and
assisting development in the community
and with the new dealer variation comes
a contribution from sanctuary housing
association of one million pounds for
entering to the agreement
happy to take any questions if required
for this report
thank you members any questions
council award
thank you chairman
it's actually a comment i'm very pleased
to see this has now been resolved
there are items and i am pleased that
we've got a new working relationship
with sanctuary
thank you councillor ward any other
members wish to comment
okay
i just before we go to the
recommendation
um
i just want to actually
pay tribute
to
[Music]
the tenacious right honourable mark
francois
who when i became leader
he drew my attention to certain issues
which existed in the transfer of 2016
and i think it's quite right to
acknowledge
that the
deputy chief executive how nice it is to
say the words deputy chief executive uh
the
deputy leader um the right honourable
mark francois myself
set about quite a considerable piece of
work and it was acknowledged by
sanctuary that there were certain
shortcomings which hadn't really been
addressed
and
i think that's really as far as i want
to go because the relationship with
sanctuary is good
this is a very positive
contribution on their part
to recognise those
past shortcomings
and certainly it's money that
can be well used within this authority
so i thank the chief executive for his
report
and certainly the work that you have
done in recent months uh to bring this
to a very satisfactory conclusion so
it's actually praise and thanks all
round so uh
unless there's anyone else that wishes
to comment
we'll go to
the recommendation
at 1.1 which is to enter into a new data
variation the new deed of variations
that will be known with sanctuary
housing association sanctuary is that
agreed
great great
thank you very much indeed
we move on to item eight the advice
services contract 2022 20
and
council williams are you going to be
speaking on this or are you
thank you chairman
thank you members this is the decision
being recommended this evening is to
agree the outcome of the advice services
tender and of all and award the advice
services contract 2224
to citizens of
advice south essex
also to recommend that the report is
presented for council in july
2022 to endorse the proposal set out in
the following
the only bid for the contract received
was from citizens advice
south end essex
however the tender submission met all
the requirements of the specification
the case was able to demonstrate using
the organization
local experience of need the social
value interventions community engagement
all of which will be able to add value
to service provided by the council
thank you members
thank you very much indeed councillor
williams um
members any uh
anyone with any questions
right okay thank you um
with no questions we'll go straight to
the decision
uh at 1.1
which says to agree the outcome of the
advice services tender and award the
advice services contract 2022
to 2024 to citizens of vice south essex
is that agreed agreed
and we moved to 1.2 recommendation which
says to recommend that this report is
presented to full council in july 2022
to endorse the proposal as set out in
the sections below
is that agreed
thank you
that takes us on to item number nine
the sustainability strategy consultation
document
and that's to consider the report of the
assistant director place and environment
seeking approval for undertaking public
consultation on the draft sustainability
strategy establishing the rockford
environmental business alliance riba
and the rochford climate change and
sustainable sustainability partnership
rccsp
and to approve allocation of twenty
thousand pounds from general balances to
support consultation and engagement on
the strategy my goodness i feel as if
i've written the report or read the
report out already councillor sperring
thank you jim
um
as you say uh mr hartin has produced a
very comprehensive appraisal and
recommendations of our next step forward
in relation to
carbon neutrality and how we can improve
the situation
in this district
as you probably are all aware we are
slightly behind brentwood in our
progress in this area but with the
support of their environmental officer
ms west
and our own new
recycling officer miss conroy
we hope this is all going to be part of
moving the progress forward
we are slightly behind brentwood but we
are using their experience and using
their their knowledge as how we can
progress this quickly
um we have also sustained produced a
little booklet the sustainable strategy
22 to 27 which perhaps you can give that
some consultation
obviously this initial 20 000 pounds is
for the consultation
further down the road there may be the
the need for further funding or more
resource but i think that's for another
day leader
thank you council sparing
any do you wish to add any further
mr holton
um
thank you on a sort of very sort of
practical note that um the the draft i
think that you've got attached to the
report is very much an early draft so
we've got a sort of a later draft
um that's that's to the hot off the
press today that uh
in practical terms i may ask you to have
to peruse before you leave just so if
there's any comments on its style or
design they'll be gratefully received
for you finalize the uh the sort of the
actual sort of booklet thank you
thank you very much indeed members any
questions before we move to the
recommendations
now
i just want to say uh that the i think
the carbon neutral working group have
felt um a little bit unloved in the
sense that their committee was set up
and they've done a lot of good work but
what this report does is it does
actually put some structure around the
whole process
and allocates funds
so that we are taking what we committed
to a while ago
a very responsible approach but in a
more structured and delivered way what i
will say is that our council services
over the past few years have been
reflecting the need to
become
carbon neutral by the year 2030 we just
haven't articulated it particularly well
and i look at some of the draft
documentations as we've seen tonight
coming out i really do think we're
really going up a level in terms of
selling ourselves and our commitment
to something which is extremely
important to us and our community
and when i look at the waste contract
when i look at what we're doing in
planning in terms of our new local plan
our asset delivery program where we are
insisting that we look at briam
excellent
and the general behavioural
attitudes within our authority towards
the responsibility of being carbon
neutral
and setting ourselves as an example to
partners
around the district because people do
look to us to set an example be an
example
and whilst our own
contribution to the process is
relatively small
working with partners uh it increases
considerably so thank you very much i'm
really pleased i promised a while back
that we would really put some impetus
behind this this work
and i'm really pleased to hear the
report so thank you councillor spurring
and thank you marcus hotland for all the
work that you've done on that
so unless there's any other comments
i'll turn to the
decisions being recommended at
1 1.1
to approve undertaking public
consultation on the draft sustainability
strategy as appended is that agreed
thank you
1.2 to establish the rochford
environmental business alliance reba
working in consultation with the carbon
neutral member working group is that
agreed
thank you
1.3 to establish the rochford climate
change and sustainability partnership
rccsp
working in consultation with the carbon
neutral member working group agreed
agreed
and to support the allocation of twenty
thousand pounds from the general
balances to provide support for
consultation and engagement on the
strategy
agreed agreed so that was all
unanimously agreed and
i just note the fact that uh in our
budget statement there was challenge um
towards allocating funds what we have
actually done very effectively uh is
allocated an appropriate amount of money
to
start delivering so if there was any
doubt about our commitment in full
council a few weeks ago this is it
twenty thousand pounds uh as a start
towards this initiative thank you very
much indeed members
moving on to the annual review of the
business plan uh and uh at that point i
will pass over again to the chief
executive to talk us through that one
thank you again chairman thank you
members in front of you we've got report
item 10 on your agenda the annual review
of the business plan for 2020 23.
um just remind members in
2017 february 2020 um this council
approved the business plan from 2020 23.
what you've got in front of you tonight
is a new format version business plan
with um annual review and performance
for 2021
um 22.
um just to make clear for members and
i'm sure everybody's well aware it's
just the council's always had very well
established performance monitoring what
you've got in front of you tonight is a
new version look and feel is to make it
easier for
every audience to read the performance
of the council and one of the key things
is ensuring that we do
monitor performance but also celebrate
success so um this report in front of
you um and the appendix a um with regard
the annual report um review um hopefully
demonstrates that i'm happy to take any
questions if required
thank you very much indeed council award
ward
it's just it's actually just a comment
as much as anything
i shared this
with
a member of the public my wife who
looked at it
and thought it was really good it's the
first time she's seen it
and she thought it was excellent so
you know that that to me speaks a lot
that it really hit home and she thought
it was a very good report thank you
thank you council award for your survey
of one out of one and you've got 100
that's uh good news it's like so many
surveys we see around the district where
89 people are canvassed and
they give their
their views and it's presented in a
percentage but
there we are um
right thank you where did we go from
here any other comments council fd
thank you
thank you um i hesitate to bring this up
really but
just
reading the first page of the first bit
welcome to how we're working to help you
shape your future
i was just looking at and thinking
working to help you shape our future
because we're part of
welsh district
i don't know just
maybe seems more slightly better i'm not
sure
unless it's too late to change it
because we've printed a thousand of them
chairman if if it helps i can um answer
that question that was the strap line
originally adopted um when the business
plan was approved in uh 2020 so it's
just a straight lift from that document
as it says in the report we'll be
looking to review our business plan
priorities in 2022 as we come to the end
of the business plan period so we'll
have an opportunity to look at it at
that point okay great that's good
that was it thank you thank you very
much and indeed it is still in draft
format and i think we still welcome any
contributions um that members might have
at the last moment council web thank you
chairman it's just a comment really
reflection i guess just looking through
this document and particularly pages 10
10 10 10 11 10 12
um and 10 13. it outlines some truly
excellent performance by watching
district council and when you look at
those numbers and those infographics
they are truly stunning and i think we
are right and proud of this local
authority for the work that we've done
um and i think this document sets out
incredibly well so thank you to everyone
that brought it together
thank you very much indeed councillor
webb and um you echo totally my
sentiments um
that we punch way above our weight uh
councillor smith um i have to admit i
have also carried out a survey with a
hundred percent take-up
of the one person
um
that being mrs smith and she she has a
particular thing about proofreading uh
and it not only applies to to this but
also to
rochefort district matters which is
already circulated and so on um and uh
there there is a an element of our our
public that are quite particular about
grammar and spelling for stops and
expressions
and um
the the survey did conclude that the
quality of proofreading
grammatically did need to improve
somewhat so i i
that the the recommendation from the
survey is that um
we we the the quality of proofreading is
enhanced somewhat please councillor
smith thank you very much indeed for
making that point um i have had a
private discussion
with the chief executive and whilst
welcoming all these documents that are
coming out and really in fast time
raising the profile of the authority
not because it's doing particularly any
better but what we're doing is we're
selling and marketing ourselves
but what we've also got to do is to
express ourselves in
good quality english with punctuation
and capital letters
and all sorts of others
your point is well made um
in
the vein but uh we're getting the stuff
out there but you're absolutely right
people do make a judgment on on this
stuff and we don't want to discredit
good messages with that type of approach
so i'm happy that my survey has been
useful you get my total support so
that's the second second survey of the
night
um
right the only um
and and the great thing about being a
partner with another great council is
the fact that if you attend their
meetings you pick up certain ideas uh
and on the brentwood version of the
similar report because all councils are
required to have their business plans
and sometimes business plans go into a
dusty draw and get forgotten about what
we're doing is actually action planning
and saying what the results are how
we're
we're monitoring
but what did strike me was a very
striking couple of pages which are just
sort of headline figures and with your
agreement i have asked us to
not put brentwood's figures in but make
sure we put rochefort's figures in
because i think they're quite striking
and very very impressive when you look
at the number of bins you know in
brentwood 5.5 million curbside waste and
recycling collections made each year
that is the scale of what we're talking
about um and
but we need to change the figure for
rochford um probably we hope it's 5.6
million just to sort of uh outdo
brentwood but uh um marcus hotlin is
just trying to work that one out so do
the maths on it but
with your agreement i would like a
couple of pages added which
which bring it out in very visual format
it's actually in there already
but certainly again i would like to
thank the deputy chief executive who i
know spent many many hours of work
turning it into an attractive document
so thank you very much indeed on that
very good
if there's no other comments
i will turn to the
recommendations set out in paragraphs
1.1 and 1.2 on page 10.1
and that is at 1.1 to approve the form
of the draft annual review as set out at
appendix a
subject of course to any further minor
and typographical
amendments required by the executive
agreed agreement
and to
1.2 to recommend that the final version
of the annual review document be
completed by the chief executive in
consultation with the leader
so uh councillor smith
if there's any typographical errors in
it you can blame me personally but i
should be looking closely so thank you
very much indeed is that agreed
thank you
we move on to item 11 which is a
statement that i wanted to make publicly
we did issue a press release a week or
so ago but this is the first opportunity
there's been for me to make a formal
public statement
members of rochford district council are
saddened and disturbed by the unprovoked
aggression against ukraine a sovereign
state which has caused horrific
devastation and creating
created an escalating humanitarian
crisis
with millions displaced or affected
no words can properly describe our
feelings
as a way of expressing support for the
people of ukraine and members of our
communities who are from or who have
ties with ukraine we unreservedly
condemn the unprovoked russian invasion
of ukraine and stand in solidarity with
the people of ukraine and their families
and friends including those within the
and local to the rochford district
we stand ready to provide support to
innocent people displaced and affected
by this unprovoked russian aggression
we will work with and support the
efforts of our local communities to
provide help support and comfort to
those in need
in such exceptional circumstances
rochford district council is making a
special provision by setting aside a sum
of 25 000 pounds to support the work
aiding the ukrainian people here in
rochford
this is the maximum permitted within the
leaders spending authority and reflects
the significance of how we feel
an immediate donation of five thousand
pounds will be made to our community
partner the community hub at the mega
center in raleigh to assist with their
work
already 60 tons and i suspect by now
many more
of essential supplies have been
transported to those in need
the hub has stopped taking in donations
and that's material donations at this
time but continues to raise money to
help families and people affected by war
the council is also part of the essex
wide partner planning discussions on how
best to support the government's homes
for ukraine scheme locally
thousands of people
many hundreds of thousands actually in
the uk have so far signed up for the
scheme where the government will provide
350 pounds a month to those selected to
house refugees
the council will support local people
who join the scheme helping ensure the
safety and welfare of refugees in our
community and work closely with essex
county council on the provision of
education on health services
from the capital sum
the council this council i should say is
setting aside twenty thousand pounds so
that's twenty thousand from the overall
twenty five thousand
and examining plans to provide a
financial support scheme for local
households who take in families the aim
being to provide a top-up of 100 pounds
per household for a three-month period
when further details about the national
sponsorship scheme become clear more
information will be made available
and i turn to louisa moss who is
obviously coordinating
that under her
under her directorship so thank you very
much indeed lorisa for all the work that
you're doing behind the scenes
excuse me
proud of the generosity and support our
residents have shown to the ukrainian
people in their hour of need the council
is now looking at what we can do to
ensure that local people who open their
homes through a ukrainian family are
supported in their efforts thank you
that concludes my formal part of the
statement what i would like to do is
just acknowledge additionally
that over 10 000 pounds was raised by
the chairman of this council councillor
judy gooding
that was raised at her recent civic
dinner through a auction and a raffle
where people gave very generously and
she actually raised just over 5 000
pounds
but that will be much funded by the
government's deck appeal so
that raises
a further 5 000 pound
so that makes a total of over 35 000
pounds that is coming from this
authority to assist in the ukrainian
crisis
also i want to make the point that we
have become aware that there are russian
families
in our communities
and we stand by them too
we
respect the fact that it is a russian
invasion of ukraine but under no
circumstances will we tolerate or put up
with any hate crime or any inappropriate
behavior to russian families in our
community
thank you members
that completes my statement it actually
completes this meeting and we close it
at 809. thank you
[Music]